it seems like a lot of indie filmmakers
don't want to cross the line in terms of
quotes selling out and and that really I
think may prevent them from going
further how do you think someone gets
over that oh this is gonna sound so
crazy you're not going to expect it all
I'm like a really big hip-hop nerd I
just loved hip-hop music I worked def
jam in different places and produce
music videos k RX one who is one of you
know are you believe for some one of the
great embassies of all time said that if
you're 18 and you're not again if you're
18 and you're not against the system
there's something wrong with you and if
you're 25 and you're not part of the
system there's something wrong with you
so have that kind of philosophy you can
be have a rebellious spirit you can have
a point of view an objective that you
want to get across but understand that
there's things larger at ahead play than
you and your crusade is only going to
come off as self-righteous and again
fall on deaf ears so not to say it's not
selling out to put on a suit and do an
interview to talk about your movie this
is not now certain certain directors
David Fisher for example you don't see
him doing premieres and donating some
he's a hell of a talented director like
he is one of the best directors of the
last 20 years we can say right indie
otherwise studio doesn't matter he's a
good sense of his voice he knows the
stories he wants to tell and he doesn't
do all the other stuff but I guarantee
you there are parts of David Fincher's
job that he does that she doesn't want
to do you know he whether it's meeting
with a financier to get money for a
movie whether it's sitting down with an
actress who might feel uncomfortable
about a certain scene or talking with
the head of marketing at a studio he
might not want to do any of that
but he understands that it's part of the
job i I don't know one job on the planet
not one job in the planet that doesn't
come with some responsibility of doing
some things that you don't want to do as
much as you want love your job
I love my job to go to work every day
talk to creative people and see movies
early and travel there plenty of things
that I don't like about my job I got all
these receipts here okay all these
receipts from trips that I need to like
fill out expense reports on it if I was
just like you know I don't want to do it
selling out it's good i don't want to
get this money back no I cure yourself
like there's parts of your job you have
to do that are part of your job and I
don't I learned that our early on and I
remember that is sometimes I can get
frustrated about something or I don't
know but for indie filmmakers answer
your questions who will feel like
they're selling out you're not selling
out if if you're if you're true to
yourself and you're not compromising
yourself so it might be selling out to
Colonel make a movie simply because you
think it will be popular even if you
don't like the movie but there's a
philosophy of do one for them one for me
that has brought a lot of people's
success so if that's something you can
do and be comfortable with then don't I
don't know you have to kind of know
yourself on some level so but but not
but not getting your own way that if
that makes sense you know a lot of a lot
of filming a lot of people just in
general life can get in their own way
with their own baggage in their own
and I do it all the time my agents will
be the first tell you I do that all the
time but get over yourself and realize
there's something larger at play here
and you can do more look at like Morgan
Spurlock we talked about before the
interview he's somebody who stays true
to his own voice navigates the the muddy
Hollywood waters is able to make the
kind of projects he wants to make and he
can stand up on a mountain and say hey
this is my movie and I'm proud of it but
I guarantee you there plenty of things
Morgan does that maybe he's not
100-percent excited about doing but
realizes he has to do for this is his
job so i don't know i think the days of
the self-righteous filmmaker are just
are down
tomorrow we were reading my mind because
I was just about to bring him up what is
the Morgan Spurlock it factor the Morgan
Spurlock it factor that's a good title
for a book yes you're right um is it is
is enthusiasm intelligence and and and
and a love of what you do and just a
respect for what you do you know he's
somebody who you go to like the Toronto
Film Festival and you're waiting on line
to see a movie at three in the afternoon
you're waiting to see a hundred you're
waiting 127 hours to see 127 hours
Morgan's in line with the other
filmmakers with the other fans with
other press people talking to people
taking pictures waiting on line to go
see 127 hours right he's at Toronto for
his own movie but he just loves movies
and so he just jumps into the culture of
movies um malin akerman is a buddy of
mine I saw her waiting on line at eleven
o'clock at night and sunday is to go see
your sister sister with her friends no
special VIP actress pass she bought a
ticket on the website waited in line
when saw the movie because she loves
mark to class and was that Sundance and
wanted to see a cool indie so I don't
know the people for there's Morgan
Spurlock it factor or anybody who's
successful at their craft in Hollywood
loves loves what they do and totally
dives in headfirst I want to see brave
at ten o'clock in the morning tomorrow I
you know I went saw a movie last night
late you know I I'm gonna I don't know I
just love you know I've got a an indie
film I've been tracking for a while I
wanted to see it I made a call this
morning to get the publicist to send me
the DVD I'm gonna watch it this weekend
get back to around monday as my thoughts
I'm not covering it for extra I'm not
covering if I just been interested in
the filmmaker and want to see their work
I don't know you just you just dive in
it and I think that's the Morgan
Spurlock it factor is that he goes head
first into his craft he watches other
movies he's not so self involved with
his own project said he know it bothers
me a lot of times when actors say oh I
don't have a chance to see anything else
I just do my movies like I don't my
favorite actors I know have a real love
movies
and the most successful actors I feel
like do when they watch other actors and
they watch other they track directors so
for any indie filmmaker out there who's
working hard on their script go read
five other scripts you know go read a an
old movie you love or you find a movie
love go and read the script for it if
you're a writer if you're a director go
watch some other movies commercial indie
foreign whatever my god just jump into
it at first
you